everyone knows that fiat currencies and
central banks they got a lot of stuff
going on it's super complex and nuanced
but there's a lot of charades it's a
confidence game and recently jon stewart
on a podcast asked a former central
banker what he thought about all this
and i gotta say i'm absolutely blown
away by what was said
literally the central bankers are now
saying the secrets out loud don't
believe me here's the clip that's going
viral all over the internet how much
currency
that has been sort of created out of
thin air has been added into this
economy through the fed what would you
put as a figure would it be six trillion
is that
too much it would be you know six
trillion in in terms of deposits with
the banks and currency he's six to seven
trillion okay that they're that they're
just injecting into it sort of out of
nothing out of nothing they're they're
the it's the central bank of the united
states
it's just another form of government
debt
am i making sense it you know it makes
sense in the make-believe world of
conjuring like there is a certain part
of this that all feels like a mirage to
some extent do you know what i mean it
all seems sort of fake well it it is
it's it's a fiduciary system it's all
faith-based
right
oh my lord yes you got to have
confidence in that currency in that
dollar because there's nothing back and
there's no gold backing so it's it's in
some ways it's a mass delusion well
now of course it is absolutely hilarious
to see jon stewart learning getting red
pill
and also hearing it directly from a
central banker's mouth there is nothing
backing fiat currencies it's all a
confidence game it's make-believe it's a
mass delusion these are terminologies
that used to be thrown around by
conspiracy theorists or in corners of
the internet but now we literally have
one of the most famous talking heads in
the world and jon stewart going ahead
talking directly to a former central
banker and him confirming all of it when
the central bankers start to say the
secrets out loud people need to pay
attention this is a great way to orange
build the people in your life send it to
your friends send it to your family send
it to your cousin your brother your mom
or your wife send it to everyone because
when the central bankers start to say
the secrets out loud
all of a sudden people start to pay
attention they say why am i trusting all
of my net worth all of my portfolio all
of my financial well-being in something
that is simply a confidence game if on
the edge case confidence was lost that
would be bad now of course i have
dollars my brothers have dollars and so
does everyone watching this the dollar
is a global reserve currency but more
and more people are waking up and saying
maybe i shouldn't have 100 dollars maybe
i should actually have a hedge maybe
it's a chaos hedge maybe it's insurance
but maybe you should get some in case it
catches on in the words of satoshi
nakamoto and so seeing this is pretty
incredible jon stewart learning and
laughing central bankers admitting all
the secrets i think we are starting to
see the erosion of trust the erosion of
the illusion and ultimately the entire
world is getting orange built